it's a quirk of our minds that not every
emotion we carry is fully acknowledged
understood or even truly felt there are
feelings that exist in an unprocessed
form within us a great many worries may
for example remain disavowed and
uninterpreted and manifests themselves
as powerful directionless anxiety under
their sway we may feel a compulsive need
to remain busy fear spending any time on
our own or cling to activities that
ensure we don't meet what scares us
head-on these activities might include
internet pornography tracking the news
or exercising compulsively a similar
kind of disavowal can go on around hurt
someone may have abused our trust made
us doubt their kindness or violated our
self-esteem but we're driven to flee a
frank recognition of an appalling degree
of exposure and vulnerability the hurt
is somewhere inside us but on the
surface we are dropped a brittle good
cheer jolliness being sadness that
doesn't know itself we numb ourselves
chemically or else we adopt a carefully
nonspecific tone of cynicism which masks
the very specific wound that's been
inflicted on us we pay dearly for our
failure to process our feelings our
minds grow unoriginal from a background
fear about their contents
we grow depressed about everything
because we cannot be sad about something
we can no longer sleep insomnia being
the Revenge of all the many thoughts
we've omitted to process in the day we
need compassion for ourselves we avoid
processing emotions because what we feel
is so contrary to our self-image so
threatening to our society's ideas of
normality and so at odds with who we
would really like to be an atmosphere
conducive to processing emotions would
be one in which the difficulties of
being human were warmly recognized and
charitably accepted we fail to know
ourselves not out of laziness or casual
neglect it simply hurts a lot processing
emotions requires good friends two deft
therapists and ritual moments like
philosophical meditation in which our
normal defenses can safely be put aside
an unfamiliar material ring-fenced for
investigation the outcome of processing
our emotions is always an alleviation in
our general mood but first we must pay
for our self-awareness with a period of
mourning in which we gradually
acknowledge that in some area or other
life is simply a lot sadder than we
would want it to be we publish new
thought-provoking films every week be
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
take a look at more of what we have to
offer at the link on your screen now